les décisions des israéliens sur une
extension de leur souveraineté sur ces
territoires sont des décisions qui
reviennent aux israéliens je crois que
le premier ministre israélien a fait
sien notre objectif c'est à dire que
notre vision pour la paix au
moyen-orient soit couronnée de succès
par ces mots washington donne de facto
son feu vert à israël pour l'annexion de
pans entiers de la cisjordanie occupée
les états unis veulent voir le plan de
donald trump pour le proche orient se
concrétiser les projets d'annexion
rencontre pourtant une opposition
grandissante à l'onu son secrétaire
général a d'ailleurs demandé ce mercredi
à israël de renoncer à ces plans qui
pourraient mettre fin aux efforts
internationaux en faveur de la création
d'un état palestinien viable
cette annexion si elle était mise en
oeuvre constituerait une violation des
plus graves du droit international
nuirait sévèrement à la perspective
d'une solution à deux états et
amoindrirait les possibilités d'une
reprise des négociations si les
palestiniens sentent qu'il n'y a pas de
perspective pour une résolution
pacifique du conflit
cela ne fera que créer des opportunités
pour des radicaux des personnes avec des
intentions dévastatrice pour venir
remplir ce vide des mises en garde
lancées sans pour autant parler de
sanction lors d'une visioconférence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu toute
dernière rencontre internationale avant
la possible mise en oeuvre dès le 1er
juillet de ses plans d'annexion pour le
chef de la diplomatie palestinienne
riyad al malki tout annexion de
territoires palestiniens par israël
serait un crime
quant à la diplomatie israélienne avait
réagi par la voix de son ambassadeur à
l'onu devant le conseil
il a reproché aux palestiniens d'avoir
refusé de venir négocier avec son pays
rejetait en bloc par les palestiniens le
projet de l'administration américaine a
aussi été dénoncé par l'une
européenne et la ligue arabe annexé des
parties du territoires palestiniens
occupés constituerait si cela se
concrétise il menace sérieuse à la
stabilité régionale ce plan détruirait
toute idée de paix à l'avenir dans ce
climat de crainte à la proche du 1er
juillet le mouvement armé palestinien le
hamas a lui haussé le ton la résistance
considère cette décision d'annexion de
la cisjordanie et de la vallée du
jourdain comme une déclaration de guerre
contre notre peuple palestinien
la résistance dans cette guerre sera un
gardien fidèles de ce peuple et de ses
lieux saints dans le détail ce plan pour
le proche-orient des états unis prévoit
l'annexion par israël de la vallée du
jourdain et de la centaine de colonies
en cisjordanie où sont installés 450
mille israéliens des colonies pourtant
illégales au regard du droit
international
s'ajoute à cela la création d'un état
palestinien sur un territoire réduit est
mort seul et sans jérusalem est pour
capitale
les palestiniens réclament des sanctions
et envisage désormais de saisir la cour
internationale de justice